welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day 30 and
we're gonna learn the
must read books that billionaires say
you have to pick up
enjoy
[Music]
did you surround yourself with mentors
how did you who did you look to for
advice
i read a lot of books and talked to lots
of people um
i didn't have any any one person who was
a mentor but i
i always look for feedback from from
people around me and
feedback from uh in historical context
you know which is books basically um so
that's um
any any book stand out is something that
was like something that you really
relied
upon or well uh they just general
business books or
i didn't read actually very many general
business books um
but i i uh i i liked
biographies and autobiographies i think
those are pretty helpful
um so i like um
and actually some little really business
although like somebody like franklin's
uh both his autobiography and say the
biography that's recently been written
by uh or not that recently but in
i guess five or ten years ago when it
was written a biography by isaacson
on on the franklin is really good uh you
can sort of
see how he kind of because he was an
entrepreneur i mean he sort of
uh started from nothing
actually just like a runaway kid
basically and uh created his
printing business and um just sort of
how he went about doing that and
and then over time he also did science
and politics so that
i would say certainly he's one of the
people uh i most admire like
franklin's pretty pretty awesome but
then i think it's also worth reading uh
books on
scientists and engineers tesla obviously
um did you hear about that tesla museum
that they're having
built yeah i actually contributed some
funding to to
save the land oh that's great yeah
awesome yeah that was a very cool thing
that oatmeal did
yeah i thought it was pretty cool i like
i like the the way that they put it too
it's like let's have a go damn test the
museum
i like biographies in general
biographies i think are really always
you know really interesting read um
what do you learn from them well i think
you learn a lot depending upon
you know whose life you're reading about
um there are lots of lessons in there
i read isaacson's biography of jobs
which i thought was quite interesting
and i actually really liked his
biography of benjamin franklin
who i would say certainly one of my
heroes he seemed like a really great guy
basically i sort of was thinking about
this when i was when i was a kid and um
trying to find some meaning in life like
what's the meaning of life you know
and um i got quite sort of
sad about it actually when i was a
teenager and then i read the
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
uh which basically said like the real
the real
you know basically universe is the
answer and you just need to figure out
the questions
so i think um you know that that's
if if i can help kind of figure out the
questions
uh then that i consider that to be
meaningful
i like i you know i've always liked
reading biography but
since the the computer's changed my life
i i now find myself playing bridget on
the computer about 10 hours a week and
unfortunately
i didn't want to give up sleep or eating
uh or
or berkshire so the reading has been
kind of light
on on investment books if you're asking
about that i would i would recommend
the first two books that phil fisher
wrote uh back around 1960 common sense
and uncommon profits in the second one
those are very good books
you know i obviously recommend first and
foremost
the intelligent investor with chapters
eight and twenty are the ones that you
really should read
two of the well all of the important
ideas in
investing really are in that book uh
because there's only about three ideas
and those two two of them are emphasized
in those two chapters
uh uh actually i think john trains
money masters is a is an interesting
book uh
during the shutdown i had extra time to
read
there are five books that i highly
recommend
the choice by dr edith eager
that's a hell of a story the woman was a
16 year old girl
in auschwitz she eventually does survive
and
gets out and moves to texas and becomes
this
inspirational therapist and after
because her story happens how she helps
other people when somebody traumatizes
you
the way you think about yourself and
your happiness and how you relate to the
world
you can't control being a victim but you
can control your victimhood
it's kind of a hopeful story but it's a
very tough story
cloud atlas by david mitchell it's such
an unusual book
and it's clever you go through six
different epics in history
where you have people making moral
choices where you see
how self-centered and bad people can be
and how
supportive and good people can be you
really do feel he captures these
different worlds it's a grand story
about human nature enduring
human values the ride of a lifetime
by bob iger it's hard to overstate how
demoralized and messed up disney was
things weren't in great shape when they
got rid of eisner and i do
consider it brilliant of iger that
indonesia
where networks are not important and
you're going to have to go direct to
consumer that you've got to have a
critical mass of the greatest
content he did a really good job
of explaining what the job of the ceo is
the great influenza by john berry he
explains
how infections work and how the immune
system works
the 1918 spanish flu is the first world
epidemic where it basically hits the
entire world
at the same time the world was faced
with this challenge
they tried to come up with drugs or
therapeutics
none of those efforts were successful
distancing
and masks and seeing who's coughing that
was all they had
if you read this you will understand a
lot
good economics for hard times by abajid
banerjee
and esther to flow this is the most
important book of the group
because it really is about what do we
know
in the field of economics that can take
the current divisions
and try and do better it's global but
it's mostly about the us
but it's addressing the big issues of
the day about
people in depressed areas how can we be
so rich and so many people
feel a lack of purpose why aren't we
better
with economic knowledge of creating
more opportunities if you want to solve
these problems there's a lot
still to learn john brooks is an
unbelievable business writer
he's probably my favorite and it's too
bad
so many people haven't had a chance to
care about him and the great work he did
he loved stories with vivid characters
venal
bumbling brilliant you name it he loved
them
he was a novelist at heart and he found
a lot of good stories
in wall street uh warren buffett gave me
a copy of business adventures
feeling like with our dialogue about
trying to understand the world of
business
that i'd enjoyed as much as he had and
in fact
it was phenomenal oh i knew he'd like it
i mean that was written for him it was
written for me too
if you're gonna run a company you should
read the impacted philosophers i mean
when you
learn how really probably pretty decent
people
start behaving in bad ways it's that's
fascinating
he talks about these people in ge who
would wink when they would actually
say what the rule book said to do now
remember you cannot talk to our
competitors about this
wink you know which is essentially
saying go talk to them he makes it come
alive in a particular way he makes it
come alive as common
because he understands that most of the
time if you look closely enough
the motives of the people involved are
as
short-sighted and self-seeking as all
other human motives and that's the
material economy
ford motor company was super successful
they
introduced a car called the edsel and
they spent more money
on picking the name and planning the
features
than it ever been spent on any new
american product
and yet it was an abysmal failure
ford counted on selling at least two
hundred thousand exiles the first year
there may be an aborigine somewhere in a
remote rainforest
who hasn't yet heard that things failed
to turn out that way
i just loved that line and yet in a way
the edsel wasn't so bad
it embodied much of the spirit of its
time or at least
the time when it was designed early in
1955.
it was clumsy powerful dowdy gauche
well-meaning a de kooning woman i think
you can read this book today
and learn a lot all the work of michael
lewis comes directly from brooks
i mean he really was the michael lewis
of his day the rules of
running a great business value creation
are
unchanged and brooks took some very
dramatic examples
that are particularly fun and
interesting and and instructed
i started bridgewater out of a
two-bedroom apartment
in 1975. um
and i've brought it to where it is now
uh
according to fortune it's the fifth most
important
private company in the united states
it's been successful it's been good
and that my objective at this particular
stage
is to help others be successful without
me i learned along the way
certain principles
every time i would make a decision i
would write down the reasons i would
make that decision
and i um
put them out i debated them and i
developed these principles so think
about principles as just being these
reasons for making a decision if you're
in this
this situation how do you deal with it
um
it was also very important to me uh to
operate in a very unusual way that
seemed
very sensible to me and it's an idea
meritocratic way
so i want to describe bridgewater as
being an
idea meritocracy in other words a real
idea meritocracy
which i'll explain and show to you so
real idea meritocracy
in which the goals are meaningful work
and meaningful relationships
meaningful work i mean you're on a
mission that you feel you're on a
mission together
to do those great things and meaningful
relationships
meaning that you care about each other
it's part of a community and to be on
that mission together and that was
really good
great in terms of our success but it was
meaningful work and meaningful
relationships
through radical truthfulness and radical
transparency
that means literally people saying
anything that they feel
that they want to say in terms of being
polite of course but
but sharing what they really believe is
true and working themselves through
to have an idea meritocratic way and to
literally
um record everything for everybody to
hear
so i mean literally they're a
combination of videos and tapes of
all meetings that happen so that nothing
is hidden
because you can't have a real idea of
meritocracy if you can't see things
yourself
and so it's a very unusual um
place and it was the really the basis of
our success
and i want to explain that way of
operating to you because this
idea meritocratic way in which there's
meaningful work and meaningful
relationships through radical
truthfulness and radical transparency
so that you could have thoughtful
disagreement
and have ways of getting past that
disagreement
to then move on like a legal system that
has been the key to our success
so that's what i want to try to con
convey to you and i'm just going to take
a few minutes to try to go through a few
slides to give you a sense of this
you know i wanted big audacious goals i
wish big audacious goals for you
go after your goals and on your way to
your goals
you're going to encounter your problems
and your failures
right that's going to happen otherwise
you just go straight to your goals no
that's the learning process you're
counting your failures failures as part
of the learning process
from the failures what i found was great
is i
um i started to think of failures as
lessons i started to think of them as
puzzles rather than develop emotional
reactions to those failures
i sort of think pain plus quality
reflection
would make give me progress so i started
to think of um
almost the failures
like puzzles that if i could study the
puzzles
the puzzles was what would i do
differently in the future
that wouldn't produce that problem again
when it happened
so and then i would reflect well what
was the
that that would be my principles what
would i do differently in the future
if i solved that puzzle i would get a
gem
and the gem was
principle a principle to handle it
better in the future because
failure is a learning process it's an
essential part of the learning process
if you can realize that and you write
down those principles write them down
it's been fantastic so we learned those
principles
and then it would help me improve and
then i would go on to more audacious
goals
and i look at evolution personal
evolution almost every evolution
evolution of a con
company evolution of everything as being
this constant
looping process that i sort of think of
as this five-step process right
if in other words to be successful you
have to you have to do five things you
have to first you have to know what your
goals are
and go after those goals be clear on
your goals
and you will encounter problems on the
way to those goals those will be your
barriers
okay they're your tests now don't just
emotionally complain
think about them as your problems you
have to diagnose those problems to the
root cause
to get at the root cause and that root
cause might be yourself what you're
doing wrong
or what somebody else is doing wrong so
you can't depersonalize it you have to
really look at it
so that you make those changes and when
you get at that root cause
only by knowing that root cause can then
you design a way to get around that root
cause
like if you're not good at something
yourself it's okay
if you find somebody else who's good at
the things that you're not good at
because nobody can be good at everything
right so
but you have to do that you just can't
keep banging yourself in the wall
so you have to design something that's
practical to get around with it
and then you have to follow through and
do it
a lot of people come up with designs but
you have to do the thing that's
necessary
and by trying that thing that's
necessary again
you will find out are you getting to
your goals or you'll cop
or encounter your next set of problems
and so on and that i believe
is the first personal evolutionary
process that has helped me
those rules that i was able to write
down
and that you can get in these this book
principles which is why i'm passing them
along
though that those rules um we were
actually able to then to put into
algorithms
and build decision-making processes that
replicate the brain we'll get into that
in a minute
okay so um in order uh
in order to be successful in the markets
one has to be an independent thinker
in order to be an entrepreneur
one has to be an independent thinker and
bet against the consensus
and be right because the consensus in
the markets
is built into the price whatever that
anybody thinks
that's it looked into the price so you
have to think
you have to bet against the consensus
and you're going to be wrong a fair
amount of times about betting against a
consensus but in any case
you need to be an independent thinker
and for an entrepreneur you need to be
an independent thinker because that
you're inventing new stuff you're doing
something and you don't
know if you're right so in order for me
to be successful
i needed to have a bunch of independent
thinkers
in order to have them have uh be
effective
okay well now how are you going to get
this bunch of independent thinkers
to agree on anything okay i had to
have an idea meritocracy in other words
i had to have a system
that literally systematically allows for
thoughtful disagreement so that these
idea meritocratic people could then get
at the right answer because that's
fantastic if you can have that
thoughtful disagreement to get it the
right answer it's very powerful
by having that and then systemizing it
principled systems
a system for having thoughtful
disagreement for an idea of meritocracy
we could produce greater amounts of
successes we also produced
failures but we would look at that way
produce our learnings
and that what produced as a result happy
employees
who really believe in this idea
meritocratic thing and owned the company
intellectually and otherwise owned the
company and we had happy
employees and then it became easier to
attract those types of people
those types of people who believe that
you know everybody has the right to make
sense of things
and that there's a power and thoughtful
disagreement and that allowed us to
attract more people
and that was the basis of going from the
two-bedroom apartment to bridgewater now
in 2012 i did a business week cover
story on elon
and uh you know we got along pretty well
i got to spend
a bunch of time with him going through
the spacex factory we went to movie
premieres and all this stuff
and um and and you know the companies
were
very interesting and elon was much more
interesting than i'd given him credit
for before
the story um he you know i sort of
pegged him as just like a one note
techno utopian kind of guy and you know
he turned out to be this great interview
he didn't have
pr handlers around him so you could you
had access to him and he would answer
just about anything you asked him and um
and so i decided then this is a guy i
really want to write about and i
i'd been looking for a book to do and so
after i did the story a couple months
went by and then i started to feel elon
out about doing a book
and uh and i i think i either sent him
an email
or called him on the phone and i you
know i said this is what i want to do
and he said look a bunch of people have
asked me in the past and
i'm not going to i'm not going to do it
i'm not going to help you
do the book and then i went to new york
and i sold the book
anyway and i thought i would sort of
force his hand a little bit and then i
arranged another meeting with him
and i'll never forget it was on a
saturday at tesla and i came in i was
like look i've sold the book
and he said i'm still not gonna
cooperate with you
and so i spent like 18 months
interviewing hundreds of people i found
like all these
spacex and tesla employees most of whom
had left all the zip to paypal people
that he'd worked with his ex-girlfriends
his like
childhood friends and and all that stuff
and then
you know a lot of those people would
they would call back to elon and say
should i speak to him or not and he was
a pretty good sport about he there's
nobody that he told not to
and so i think that happened enough
times that um after about 18 months of
doing it
i was at home it's like 6 30 at night
on a weekday and up on my caller id it
was elon musk
and i picked up the phone and he said he
said look i can basically
this is gonna go one of two ways i can
shut down all these people that
call me and ask whether you know i
should let them talk to you or i could
cooperate with the book
i was like obviously you should choose
option number b
or option b and uh and then we set up a
meeting to
um to talk about he wanted to he wanted
to be able to
he wanted to have some control over it
initially
uh he wanted to be able to read the book
before it came out and then he wanted to
put footnotes in the book
and if you like know anything about elon
that would mean
you know the footnotes would be longer
than the book and that the book would
probably never be
published and sure so i kind of pushed
back on him on that i had this huge
speech prepared and i got like five
minutes into it and he just said okay
yeah to his credit um after that he
gave me access to everybody i wanted and
then he
agreed to have a meeting with me you
know once a month he said for as long as
it took it ended up
being about eight months and we would
have like three four or five hour
dinners
what is it like to spend a few hours a
month interviewing elon musk
it was really fun i uh at the beginning
it was nerve-racking because i
i never knew how many of these
interviews i would actually get even
though he had
agreed to it i always figured sort of
thought
you know he might do one and then he'd
be like okay that's enough
and then um and then i thought you know
he might get sick of it after a while
and just cut me off
so each one it was sort of like felt
like an accomplishment the
you know the but then it was frustrating
because the first four um
i really didn't i was getting lots of
useful stuff but nothing that was
i could tell he was still holding back a
bit and he was repeating a lot of
stories that
um if you kind of watch elon speeches
and other talks that you would have
heard before sure and so that was
frustrating
and then i'm still not sure exactly what
happened but around the fourth meeting
um you know we used to always do the
same thing we would get there
he eats really late so it'd be like 8 30
9 o'clock at night
and and we would go a few times till
just everybody had left
and it was kind of one of those things
there was like hardly anybody there
and he just it was like a flip the
switch kind of flipped he
i think he'd sort of really committed
to doing it and and he became much more
relaxed and
easy going i think every moment in the
history of business every moment the
history of technology
happens only once the next uh mark
zuckerberg will not be building a social
networking site the next larry page will
not be building a search engine
the next bill gates will not be building
an operating system company
if you're copying these people in some
sense you're not learning from them
um and and this is why i think there is
no science
to business uh science starts with the
number two
it starts with things that are
repeatable and uh you know
experimentally verifiable in one way or
another
whereas i think um uh you know um every
great company is one of a kind and and
the question
how do you get from zero to one um and
and so the starting point for my book
zero to one
is that is this sort of anti-formulaic
approach and
take this a question of singularity and
uniqueness uh
very um as the central question
um and i try to get it through a variety
of sort of contrarian questions
um what great business is nobody
building tell me something that's true
that nobody
agrees with you on these are often quite
hard questions to answer
because we think it's hard to come with
some new truth or it's
often requires courage because you often
have to go against conventional wisdom
in
one way or another i think that um all
if you're as founder or
entrepreneur what you want to aim for is
monopoly you want to aim
to build a company that is one of a kind
uh and that's so far
um differentiated from the competition
that
it's not even competing um and um and i
think this is the conventional wisdom is
always that capitalism and competition
are somehow synonyms i believe they're
antonyms a capitalist
is someone who's in the business of
accumulating capital a world of perfect
competition
is a world where all the prophets are
competed away
if you want to compete like crazy um
then you should just open a restaurant
in chicago
and um and and i think the the great
companies like
google sort of the paradigm example i
use has had no serious competition in
search since
2002 when it definitively distanced
itself from yahoo and microsoft
and as a result it's been generating
enormous cash flows
for the last 12 years dot com secrets is
the book
if you're not reading you're not growing
okay it's impossible you got to read
something warren buffett says
he spends most of his time reading so
every tuesday i want to be
bring you a book review the name of the
book is dot com secrets
there's a forward by dan kennedy dan
kennedy is known as
like one of the the like
wizards of online marketing okay now in
this book we're going to be talking
about the secret formula the value
ladder
from a ladder to a funnel just literally
literally
reading some of the titles that russell
uses in the book
has helped me figure out hey what am i
gonna how am i gonna start
like thinking with this see once you
take somebody that's got a commitment
like you have and like i have
and add a little bit of strategy to it i
guarantee you're going to figure out
with this book dot com secrets
you're going to figure out how to build
click funnels
that actually turn into profits for you
okay
how to find your dream customer i'm
interested three types of traffic
wow what are they i didn't know there
was three types of traffic okay
your communication funnel now now that
makes sense to me because every
communication i got people watching me
on facebook or snapchat or youtube or
in my email lines or out there at the
street corner or maybe it's at the bank
these are different types of
customers and i have to might
i might have to uh be a different type
of
person for them i might have to tell a
different type of story
whether i'm talking to somebody about my
real estate or i'm trying to get a loan
for something
or i'm trying to sell a 995 product
those are all different stories and i
need to be sure that i
understand who who's presenting and
who's listening the attractive
character the soap opera sequence okay
got my attention daily
seinfeld sequence and kern and all these
guys kennedy
brunson they all talk about in these
terms reverse
engineering a successful funnel seven
phases of a funnel
23 building blocks of a funnel front end
and back
in funnels the best bait you need bait
man you want to catch a customer
you need some bait two-step free plus
shipping
self-liquidating offers continuity the
perfect webinar
i know something about webinars i'll
teach russell brunson something about a
webinar too
invisible funnel webinars product
launches
this is what these guys all tell me and
russell's told me grant you work too
hard buddy
i said what you got my attention now boy
he says you work too hard man
he talks in he talks in his book the
dot-com secrets the old video
uh the old media versus the new media
it used to be direct mail then email
networking then facebook
tv then youtube by the way two youtube
now has
more views over can you check out the
number
yesterday it hit some freaking
phenomenal number radio to podcast
newspaper to blogs the world's changing
and this book this book
is going to show you how to uh change
with it all right now the first thing i
want to tell you about is secret number
one in the book
i'm recommending everybody go out and
get russell brunson russell's going to
be with me
at the 10x growth con speaking
uh what they see uh speaking with me at
the 10x growth con march 17th
18th and 19th i'm bringing russell in
and i said russell man you gotta you
gotta go over the secret formula the who
the where
the bait and the result what is the
result i want
well that's pretty easy right i want
people to buy my product what is the
bait i'm gonna use
a little more difficult saturday nine
a.m
saturday 9 00 a.m that is march 18th
russell brunson's coming to miami to go
over these concepts
5 billion youtube has 5 billion videos
watched every day and there's many of
you still not using
youtube enough to create your click
funnels and support your
population of people that are going to
be seeing your content the secret
formula who
where bait now what does this mean who
is your dream client
i thought who meant who am i no no who
is your dream client
i'm like wow that's good that's good
okay
the first question i ask yourself who do
i actually want to work with
see most people just want to do business
with anybody that'll pay him i don't
want to do that
i want to do business i want people at
the 10x growth con that can pay for a
ticket
i want people to 10x growthcon that can
come with money have time
and they can add value to my life not
that just buy a ticket
so when i start clarifying this out of
russell's book i'm like
what kind of client do i want do i just
want a guy's got a thousand bucks or 5
000 bucks or 10 000
no actually what i want is a guy that is
willing to pay 10
000 and bring some staff with him i
really want somebody can spend 25 or 50
000 and probably has a company of 80 to
100 people back at his office
that he can get on our online training
program you see
it starts clarifying who do we really
want for grant cardone tv
when robert's looking for customers who
is your dream client
okay he his huh great question man
his dream client is not somebody's got
money his dream client is somebody that
wants advertising marketing
understands the value of youtube
facebook twitter
long-term organic storytelling
right here for my offices our ideal
client for our advertising at grant
cardone tv would actually be somebody
i've already done business with
right i'll give you an example of an
ideal client
uh an ideal client would be somebody i'm
already doing printing with
okay that that's maybe making our our
playbook to millions program
they do all our printing fulfillment
okay now that would be a smart guy to be
in our studio
with me and shooting ad campaigns so
that i could tell them what
it would be good for them and good for
me the ideal client dream client
would be somebody that wins as big as i
win because they give me money
right so robert would make a list of
everybody we actually give checks to
so that i could tell a story i don't
know who this guy is right
don't know him you know why because he
hadn't said hey grant you know what
rather than giving me money
okay or grant you keep buying the
products from me grant and i'll
advertise with you i like that even
better
that way i can tell my public what mr
printing abc printing
this is who i've selected i could go to
any printer in the world
this is who i spend my money with and
that would be the ad okay
so this says the secret formula who's
your dream client number two
where are they man now this gets really
in the neighborhood of who's got my
money but with russell brunson
the name of the book is dot com secrets
okay dot com secrets get it today at
amazon
you don't buy it from me you buy it at
amazon where can you find them the next
question in the secret phone is where
can you find these
ideal man or woman now it's interesting
russell talked about the ideal man or
woman
we're going to be doing on sunday sunday
morning i'm going to be doing an
ideal life what is your ideal life
okay what is your ideal customer what is
your ideal spouse
what are your ideal kits what is the
ideal thing going on
not there's eight billion people's
people on planet earth
i just want a customer okay so you got
to get clear where can i find this ideal
man or woman
where do they hang online are they on
facebook or instagram
now this i discovered
strictly out of my willingness
to learn things okay like i go on
snapchat
i don't i don't know i don't i don't
know what snapchat a completely
different energy than facebook
right even though they're owned by the
same company completely different
clientele
maybe not maybe robert's on snapchat
and he's on facebook but there's
something about his personality that
changes a little bit i did not know that
until i started playing with it i used
instagram for almost two years before i
even understood how to use it because
something about the personality was
different so russell's talking about
where are these people and by the way
are they different number three what
bait will you use to attract them
if you're on facebook what is the bait
if you're and what is bait
once we know where the dream customers
are we have to create the right bait to
attract them
what is the right bait for facebook for
youtube
what is the call to action your bait
could be a your bait could be a physical
book
a cd a dvd an audio recording oh by the
way
why a cd or a dvd when most people
aren't using cds and dvds anymore
okay i'm gonna tell you brunson's gonna
tell you this because people like
hard products okay uh one mistake that
my
office makes a lot is we don't put
things into a physical universe
so that people can see the value of it
do people really want to read this whole
book do they want it in their office
guess what just because you don't
doesn't mean
some people don't just because you don't
have a dvd player
or a cd player okay does it mean people
don't want to see this ticket
you get it so people need
physical products okay number four what
result
do you want to give them once you've
hooked your dream
customer with the perfect bait the last
question is what result
do you want to give them i'm not talking
about what product or service you want
to sell them
a business is not about products and
services a business about
the result the problem you solve is what
i talk about seller be sold
you can get for your clients once you
and they understand that concept
then price is no longer a barrier okay
so 10x growth conference what is the
result
i want from people
i want people to have the best
experience they've ever had in their
life i want an experience so positive
three days you get to spend with me
and 24 other speakers i'm talking about
the best speakers on the planet one of
which
is russell brunson these aren't just
speakers by the way
i probably demean them a bit by calling
them speakers these are people
men and women that are in business right
now
making moves okay what do i want as a
result number four
what result do i want for you for being
at this conference number one i want an
experience that you can't wipe from your
memory
okay i want you to have an experience
that will change your life forever if
you're ready for a change
i want you to come to that event and
something happens before you even get
there that's what i want
okay so who are your dream clients where
can you find them
what bait will you use to attract them
and what result do you get
chapter two secret two the value ladder
okay look like my friend john hamlin
says when value exceeds price
price is no longer an issue
if you take the value proposition the
dot-com secrets value ladder he talks
about the free
quiz as uh maybe something you want to
give to people
hey uh i got a free quiz find out what
find out your credit rating see that
that is basically
a free quiz right that's a come on to an
audience
to find out what uh what's my credit
okay
so what what are we selling right here
we're probably selling a credit repair
or a free credit card right or a
mortgage
so that's what the mortgage company's
doing they're like hey find out about
your credit what russell brunson calls
the free
quiz a free book you could use a free
book as the next part of the latter
here's a free book could be an ebook
third thing invisible
funnel webinar hey join me on wednesday
night after they've gotten the quiz
after the book
join me and i'll show you for free
or for 69.49 or whatever how you can fix
your credit without
spending any money and then there's the
home study event
so notice as you go up the value curve
okay he talks about this in click
funnels continuity probably can't see
this here great book folks worth the
read
i'm going to bring russell in he
explains what does your value
ladder look like so he's going to
actually be spending time with you
in march to go over this okay secret
three from ladder to funnel
bait front end middle backhand okay he
talks about that versus the old funnel
okay do you use a ladder going out this
way to keep
customer going in or do you build a
click funnel like so many people have
talked about for years
i don't know what's going on my throat
how to find your dream customer who are
they where are they
right where is your target marking
market
target marketing congregating who is
your target market
is everybody a target for grant cardone
no
man if you're a much more passive
like who's my customer okay my customer
is going to be people that are
probably a little more aggressive right
they they can handle the language that i
speak in they want to grow their
business
they're not just satisfied he talks
about russell talks about this in here
about what is your story okay how do you
how do you use that story to tell
a story that's acceptable to your
audience okay and when you change
audiences the three types of traffic
when you change
audiences traffic you control traffic
you don't control
and traffic you own okay this is so
important
traffic you own is the best kind of
traffic traffic you control
email ads pay-per-clicks banner ads
native ads
affiliates and joint ventures by the way
one of our affiliates made 10 grand this
month already
right so if you're not being an
affiliate with me what are you doing
okay
russell brunson's got traffic already
what does he sell he sells
this information to his public he does
not sell sales training
so me and russell could actually do
something together and expand both of
our list
the attractive character and this is
what i was just trying to get to
are you the leader the adventurer the
reporter or the reluctant hero
okay what are your character flaws what
are the parables you tell
what is your backstory what is your loss
redemption
what is the us verse them okay what is
your before
and after story what is your amazing
discovery what are the secret telling
things you do
folks the books is the books is every
day every tuesday i do this dot com
secrets okay
it's worth a read i'm three quarters of
the way through the book right now
loved every minute of it i'm bringing
russell in in march
march 18th 17th 1819
called the 10x growthcon russell brunson
will be
live to answer your questions about
click funnels
if you want to make more money you got
to learn how to use the internet of
things
okay and if you want to make more money
on the internet of things folks if
you're not amazon
if you're not apple if you don't have
unlimited budgets like most of us don't
have unlimited budgets
then you got to learn the game of
the underground playbook for growing
your company
online the book is dot-com secrets by
russell brunson
hey grant cardone here uh if you don't
know who i am i've written seven books i
want to tell you about one of them in
fact i want to give you
uh my latest book free of charge okay no
no what's the word no
uh strings attached
okay it's called the millionaire booklet
all right and the reason i want to give
you this book i have a goal to give a
million of these books away
to give you information you don't have
about money okay it is
i believe the reason number one it's my
favorite book that i've written
i've written seven books and 13 business
programs
this is my favorite book of all my books
it's simple it's
easy it's a little pamphlet 40 pages it
will
change the way you look at finances you
didn't learn this at school
you didn't learn it in college and your
mom and dad didn't teach you this i
promise you they didn't teach you this
and it is the reason why so much and so
many people are in financial trouble
this book's gonna tell you three things
you have to learn about money that even
my five-year-old and my seven-year-old
know by heart number one how to make
money
most important thing you gotta get
income you gotta figure out how to
increase your income
if you got one job you don't need to go
get a second job first you need to
figure out how to take that
job that you have that situation you're
in right now whether you like it or
don't like it
i'll promise you there's always a way to
create a
second revenue stream from that job
you're in
even if it's waiting tables
see that's my little girls right there
that's the ones that know how to do that
deal already
and you need to learn how to do that
deal by the way money is a very very
simple topic this has been over
complicated by
wall street financial planners
accountants
and they've done it for a reason they've
complicated it for a reason and just
look at your mom and dad
you know your mom and dad probably
aren't rich and uh if they are
they would agree with what i'm share
with you in this book
if they're real rich not if they're
middle class rich
so the second thing uh this book is
going to teach you is the
the phenomenon of saving money
uh it is a uh completely misunderstood
topic and most of it most of it has been
intentional
and i and i don't say that loosely or
lightly but there
has been a concerted effort on this
planet
to convince people to save money
with no real understanding
of why you were saving money
the idea was okay you're going to save
money so you can retire one day but the
truth is the reality is most people
end up just old with some money unable
to use it
constantly worried about saving they
don't do it they're not successful at it
the money sits in a savings account or
worse than that it gets pushed off to
some ira or
keo account that they can't access or
use until they're like 68 years old
so i'm going to show you the way the
only reason to save money
is so that later you can do something
with it and that's to invest
and i'm gonna lay it on a very simple
way why you save where you put it how
you put it away
when it's time to start making some
plays which brings me to number three
number three is how to multiply money is
the single most important
of all the three steps but will not
matter if you don't get number one and
number two down so look i want to give
you the book for free
go to millionairebooklet.com or just go
to the link right connected here
millionairebooklet.com forward slash
free if you can remember that or just
click the link below
i would love to hear what you were
taught about money
okay what were you talk what weren't you
taught were you taught it was good well
you thought it was bad did anybody tell
you how to save it
did they tell you how to invest it did
they tell you how to multiply it did
they talk to you
about multiple flows of income did your
parents tell you you couldn't be rich or
that rich people were bad or
hey how about this did you did your did
your parents tell you get rich
because if you don't get rich you'll
never be free look i want to help you
okay i want to help you get your
finances right this is a mission that
i'm on
i want to change the way you look at
finances i want to change the way you
and your girlfriend you and your
boyfriend you and your husband you and
your wife you and your lover
i want to change the discussion that you
have about money
finances income savings investing
multiple flows of what it takes to
actually create financial freedom
do you even want financial freedom i
want to change the way you look at are
you going to buy a house
are you going to rent it you know you're
going to invest in a keo
you're going to keep that money close to
you where you can use it yourself
are you going to invest money in
yourself are you going to invest money
in a stock
how much money do you need before you
start investing
is it five thousand ten thousand fifty
thousand a hundred thousand
are you going to buy real estate it
creates passive flows of income are you
going to invest in the stock market
are you going to be doing you know uh
the the new currencies
are you going to invest in commodities
what are you going to invest in if you
ever get money look if you don't answer
these questions if you don't confront
this topic
you're going to be confused and if
you're confused as a parent guess what
happens to those kiddos
they're going to be confused so look
it's my mission to help
you to help you starting with you i want
to get a million of these books
out all i ask you to do is this when you
get the book
it takes 20 minutes to read this book on
average thousands of people have already
gotten the book the average read time is
about 15 16 minutes
read the book in 20 minutes second thing
i ask you to do is this
do a review on it on youtube okay if you
like the book do a
review on it if you didn't like the book
if you didn't get anything new out of it
write
a write a review do a little video do a
15 20 second 30 second review throw it
up on youtube
call it the millionaire booklet review
like me or hate me i'd love to hear from
you
and the third thing if you love the book
okay
i ask you to do one thing for me in the
future and this is totally on a trust
basis
if you love this book okay if it becomes
a game changer for you like i believe it
will be
buy one book from me buy one book for me
in the future
and share it with someone else okay look
i want to help you again i want to help
you i think you can see the sincerity i
want to help you with your finances if i
had my whole career to do
all over again i would start with this
program because look money
matters money's important everybody
needs it
i want to help you with it i want to
give you the information your colleges
can't give you for a lot of reasons your
teachers don't know it
otherwise they'd be doing it your
parents didn't do it otherwise
hey they'd be telling you about this
booklet i wouldn't okay now i've got
some special bonus clips that i think
you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week also if you've already
got your billionaire mindset
companion pdf calendar get ready for
another amazing video tomorrow or if you
don't have it yet you can get it for
free in the first line of the
description below and if you're enjoying
this billionaire mindset series give me
a hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
if we encounter a man of rare intellect
we should ask him what books he reads
ralph waldo emerson today i'm going to
share
the seven books every entrepreneur
must read these are seven books that
have had a tremendous impact
on my life how i think about business
and i hope they have the same impact on
you
now i used to have a ton of books i used
to have
walls and walls of books and when i saw
something interesting i would pick it up
and buy it somebody told me to get it i
would buy it
and i found i had all of these books
just sitting on the shelves
collecting dust and i and i was
accumulating more books and i could read
and i had great intentions to read them
but i never got around to them
and and it created stress it created
stress looking at all these books
knowing i got to read
all of these things so i decided one day
i would get rid of them all
and i donated them to a local library
and i pared it down i got to my
core list of books that i read and i
reread
and i've given me so much value and
today i wanted to share them with you
and hopefully it transformed the way you
think and transforms your business as
well
okay well that was awkward test one two
one two
at number seven is the fred factor by
mark sanborn
and this is a book about delighting your
customers
it tells a story about a postman named
fred who goes over and above to always
delight
his customers which are the people on
his route and you think about being a
postman
it could be a boring job right eating
the same thing over and over and over
and over again
every single day but fred finds a way to
get to know his customers to
watch over their houses when they when
he knows they're not home or on vacation
to always look for ways to delight and
surprise them and so
if you have a business where you
personally are involved in dealing with
customers
which will be most people or if you have
people on your team who
are responsible for dealing with
customers give them this book it's a
short read
look at that look how thin that is it's
like
not even 100 pages what how many pages
100 pages
just over 100 pages super fast read
it'll change your mindset on how to work
with customers
pick it up at number six
is the go giver by bob berg
and john david may this is an awesome
book another quick read it is
what 125 pages pretty easy to sift
through
you can probably get it through in one
sitting as well and this book is all
about
giving and helps change your mindset
from being a taker and saying here are
my goals and i got to go out and take
what i can
to realizing that to accomplish your
goals you have to give
to other people help others do what
they're trying to do help others
accomplish their goals and in turn
they're going to come
back and help you and often the path to
reaching your goal
is totally unexpected and it's going to
come as a result of helping other people
so
it totally changed my mindset of
what i needed to do in business and not
just go and try to reach and
take my goals but to help others along
the path
it's an inspiring story you can't help
but feel great after reading it you
can't help but feel changed after
reading it you want to go and make the
world a better place
it's an uplifting positive awesome story
coming up number six go check it out the
go giver
coming in at number five is donald trump
the art of the deal
this is one of my favorite books because
it helps you think
big one of the biggest problems with a
lot of entrepreneurs is you're
stuck in your current bubble right the
environment that you create for yourself
is holding you back where you are
how do you bust through how do you think
bigger how do you go out and do
something that's going to change the
world
where nobody in your family has ever
done that before where none of your
friends have that kind of ambition so
how do you surround yourself with those
kind of people you read books like this
now this is one of the first i think
it's the first non-fiction book that i
ever read
i remember i was driving to new york
with my family
i don't know how old i was at the time
you know maybe teenager
driving to new york city crossing the
bridge and i was reading donald trump
out of the deal
and it just inspired me to want to do
more
to think outside my comfort zone and
this is something
that you need to do as an entrepreneur
if you want to accomplish
big things you want to achieve big goals
you have to believe
you got to believe that you can do it
so how do you get that confidence when
you've never done it nobody your
family's done nobody in your social
networks have done it
you can surround yourself with people
like donald trump read this book
you will be inspired you will be ready
to take action you'll be ready to go out
and conquer big dreams
it'll give you that extra motivational
boost and you can apply it to your
business
check it out number five donald trump
are the deal
[Music]
coming in at number four is think and
grow rich by napoleon hill
this book is awesome it says at the top
this book could
could be worth a million dollars to you
it's super helpful and
and the main thought behind this is that
thoughts
are things there's a lot of believe in
this book that
whatever you have in your mind whatever
impact you want to create in the world
whatever business you want to start
it's all possible it's all possible if
you believe in yourself and it gives you
the steps to do it
and it outlines the story of andrew
carnegie who was
at the time the richest person in in
america
and his lessons for success for people
who are coming up
how he did it himself his advice for
other people
it'll help build your confidence it'll
help you believe in yourself it'll help
you make you
ready to go out and do something
positive in the world that'll give you
the confidence and courage
to start or to continue the faith the
the motivation the inspiration to keep
going
when when you may be up against the wall
you're not seeing any progress
it's beautifully written great advice in
here as i was opening the book before
doing this video
i had the old book smell coming out at
me and give me a little bit of a
headache so uh i gotta i gotta
brush out the book a little air it out
it's an old book
but uh awesome definitely recommend
reading it i know entrepreneurs who read
this
every year as an annual ritual and every
year they take something new from it so
definitely go check it out coming in at
number four think and grow rich napoleon
hill
coming in at number three keep any
promise by kareem ismail
this is an awesome book and it's divided
into two sections okay
now kareem uh he came from a successful
business
but he was overworked it was causing
problems in his family life it was
causing problems in his in his health
and he totally changed around everything
that he did
uh and replanned his life and he gives
you the blueprint for how to do it now
it's divided into two sections
the first are stories of people and how
they've changed their life
and the second are exercises that you
can do to start changing your business
and your life
i gotta be honest i'm gonna be honest is
real talk
coming straight from evan carmichael is
what this channel is all about the real
talk is
the stories in the book
i found just okay i didn't find that
inspiring i found the problems that they
were overcoming
weren't that huge and i felt like i
wasn't on the same level with the people
who are in the book and i want to be
inspired by people who are doing more
right looking at
donald trump and looking at andrew
carnegie people who are doing a lot more
that's who i want to be inspired by
so the stories were just okay for me but
the exercises
the exercises are life-changing that's
why
it's coming in at number three if you
sit down and you do the exercises and
you follow them
the ones of cream have laid out it will
change your life the huge value here
they show the extras in the book but the
big value is here in the workbook
and i hope i hope cream still offers
this as part of the deal if you look
here it says
download the life blueprint workbook
149 value for free that's the money
that if you go through that do those
exercises
follow through on them i guarantee you
it'll change your business life it'll
change your personal life it had a
massive impact on me
and that's why i recommend it as a
number three book even if you've never
heard of it it's the secret gem for
entrepreneurs
so go check it out keep any promise by
cream ismail
coming in at number two is radicals and
visionaries by thaddeus warro
and the subtitle is entrepreneurs who
revolutionize the 20th century
this is such an awesome book what it
does is basically
tell you the stories of a whole bunch of
different entrepreneurs
and each story is only what four pages
long
five pages long so i can i can open it
up and
so here story of jeff bezos there's a
picture there's a quick quote of him
there's his story there's these little
tidbits that come out
more tidbits story and then you're done
so in like four pages
you have the history of jeff bezos and
how it got started and it does that over
and over and over again
for lots of famous entrepreneurs that
you would recognize what i found it
useful for is that it was a motivational
boost for me one you know
i believe a modern success you've seen a
lot of the videos that i do it's all
about modeling success
and that saved my business and so this
is a a quick hit
of tons of different entrepreneurs that
you can model
i used it as inspiration in the mornings
for me this this used to be my routine
you know when you wake up and you're
you're by yourself and you're trying to
challenge yourself to think bigger and
do more
and stay motivated to run your business
my daily routine used to consist of
opening up
radicals and visionaries and reading one
story and i'd get an idea from them
and i'd get get inspiration and motivate
and get some energy from them
and you can do it in a couple minutes
it's such an easy quick read
so you'll get lots of ideas from it
you'll get lots of energy from it
uh definitely worth checking out my
number two book
radicals and visionaries daddy aswaro
and coming in at number one the number
one book all
entrepreneurs must read drum roll how do
i do a drum roll
drum roll the four-hour work week by tim
ferriss
this is my favorite book of all time if
i had to pick one book to keep
this would be it and at the core
this book is a productivity book okay
it'll teach you how to automate how to
delegate how to eliminate
how to outsource how to apply the 80 20
rule to your business
how to how to be more efficient get more
stuff done
so that then you can go live the life of
your dreams it teaches you
a lot about productivity and since
reading this book i've become
a productivity nut and have applied a
lot of strategies
that tim suggests in this book to my
life to my business
and it's had dramatic impact the other
thing though that you learn from it is
tim thinks way outside the box
and even now a lot of the strategies
here are still
way way way way outside the box and
you don't even realize that some of
these things are possible that was what
i was so excited and interested
in reading from him and this is the this
is the extended and updated version so i
got the original and then i bought the
updated version
and if he puts another one out i'm gonna
buy that one too because it's awesome
but it challenges you to think
differently it challenges you to step
outside your comfort zone
it challenges you to look for other ways
to accomplish your goal that you may not
have ever thought possible
so on top of all the great productivity
advice that you get
that i get from it and taking notes and
and read through it
it also makes you think more creatively
makes you look for other options
and as an entrepreneur that's what
you're going to have to do to be
successful
because chances are it's not just going
to be the straight path to success
it's going to be a crazy wild bumpy ride
and you can't just do the things that
everybody else does
you got to be creative you got to step
outside the box that's what this book
helps you do
tim ferriss for our work week the number
one book for all entrepreneurs you must
read it
now before signing off i got to give you
my bonus book
it's the only fiction book in my
collection and i had to share it with
you
now when people look at my bookshelf you
see the steve jobs quote at the top
makes sense you see the books i don't
have a lot of them
and when they look at it they look at
the top and they see what the heck is
that three kingdoms book what is it all
about
and then they look below
and you see this statue and you're
wondering what he's all about
and those little characters underneath
and what they're all about
so i have to tell you the story so three
kingdoms also known as romance of the
three kingdoms
is one of the most popular books in
china
in all of chinese history that has then
been translated to english
and it'll teach you about leadership
it'll teach you about
motivating people teaching about having
a purpose it teaches you about honesty
and trust
and loyalty and it's a story about three
warring kingdoms at the end of the han
dynasty who are fighting for control of
china
one of them is led by a man named chocho
who is evil and
lies and cheats and steals and does
whatever it takes
to win and the people hate him and he's
very oppressive and has
tons of rules and uh and his and is the
you know the dictator and
his way has to go and and he's he's evil
and cruel
and the other side is run by a guy named
laubey
who is fair and honest and just and
treats people with respect and people
love him and they follow him
and he'll never screw people over and
these two guys are constantly fighting
and at the start laubey is losing all
the time he doesn't have the military he
doesn't have the money
he doesn't have the team and he's always
just retreating and running away
and eventually he builds up his team and
the people believe in him they continue
to follow him and they love what he's
all about
and and he starts to win and so it's all
about this
this fight that continues to happen
between those two kingdoms and another
one that's in the third that
that's not as uh not as talked about but
i love the story
it's uh it always gives me ideas about
strategy about loyalty about teamwork
and i like to pick it up i like to play
the video games i like to buy the
statues and
decorate the stuff i like to name my
products after them the zuga
that i sell come from this book other
companies that i've started have come
from this book
and so uh has a lot of deep personal
meaning to me and if you're looking for
kind of an
off-the-wall fiction book that um
challenges you that will make you think
that'll
uh be kind of outside their the zone of
usual entrepreneur how-to books
then check it out three kingdoms if you
want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there